from Sky News let's talk about brexit if
we can you have said today that you are
willing to have an extension to brexit
you will be the face of Britain's new
relations Britain tries to forge a new
relationship what it what do you think
should happen with Brick City well first
of all I think brexit is not the end of
something but it's the beginning of a
new relationship between the European
Union and the United Kingdom so we
should be very careful how we deal with
each other and secondly it is very
difficult to have brakes and therefore I
said when there are good reasons an
extension might be possible because we
should do everything not to have a hard
your approach differ at all from that of
jean-claude Juncker and his commission
no we I think we have a very good
withdrawal agreement that is dead that
the UK has said that is dead it has been
negotiated within the red lines the
United Kingdom gave us and therefore if
the situation changes this is another
game but at the moment being I'm very
close